[Musique]
dans le village ville du coin d'une
contrée lointaine l'écart et veulent se
marier avec des triangles et les
triangles veulent passer le restant de
leur vie avec des carrés 20 l'écart et
les triangles ne sont pas non plus des
traînées ne sont pas prêts à se marier
avec n'importe qui certains cas réame
étrille angle très éclatée euros tandis
que d'autres carré m et triangle presque
rectangle un anvers
certains triangle aime les grands carrés
au graff tandis que d'autres aiment
davantage les minions crétins en
particulier les compatibilité entre
carré et triangle sont limitées et on
peut les illustrés en traçant une ligne
entre couples compatibles le maire de
ville du corps vous engage en tant que
ministre de l'amour et vous charge de
jouer les cupidon en maximisant le
nombre de mariage monogame à venir et je
vous invite à reprendre l'exemple qu'on
vient de voir m oppose et a trouvé le
nombre maximal de mariage que vous
pouvez encastré n hésitez pas à chercher
mais en bon mathématicien vous vous
dites que le problème de vie du coin
n'est pas spécifique à l'île du coin si
les mariages de vie du coin sont
nombreux et heureux
alors les villes d'un côté vont vouloir
copier la politique amoureuse de vie du
coin du coup en bons mathématiciens vous
devez vous demander s'il existe une
façon systématique de résoudre ce genre
de problème ou dit plus sèchement étant
donné des individus classés en deux
groupes
et étant donné des liens de
compatibilité entre certaines paires
d'individus de groupes opposés pouvez
vous déterminez un algorithme qui
déterminera toujours le nombre maximal
de mariage monogame aussi en 1956 deux
mathématiciens ford et füle personnes
trouvèrent une jolie solution à ce
problème
leurs astuces était d'ajouter deux
points virtuels ap les sources et pluie
de relier la source au carré est de
relier les triangles aux puits de plus
il oriente r tous les liens avec une
flèche de gauche à droite maximiser le
nombre de couples formés revenait
désormais à maximiser le nombre de
chemins de 2 à 2,10 joint entre la
source et le puits pour ce faire fort
des fugues personnes propose d'abord
construire les chemins 1 à 1
le problème c'est que ce faisant on
risque de créer un mariage qui rend
beaucoup d'autres mariage impossible for
défilent carson permettent alors
d'annuler ce mariage en autorisant le
parcours du chemin correspondant mariage
en sens opposé on parle alors de grâce
les i duels et bien fort des foules
personnes prouve que tant qu'on peut
trouver un chemin de la source aux puits
dans le graphe résiduelles un peu
strictement augmenter le nombre de
mariages mieux encore dès que le craf
résiduelles n'admet plus de chemin de la
source aux puits on sait que
l'arrangement des mariages qui
correspond à ce graphe résiduelle est
optimale on aura alors résolu le
problème des mariages et pendant des
années vis du coin fut surnommée la
ville de l'amour sauf qu'au fil des
années cette ville de l'amour fut ternie
par des histoires de tromperies voir des
affaires de divorce
le problème c'est que vous aviez par
exemple marié m² au lof twingo et vous
aviez marié poincaré aux white stripes
gaulle sauf que six points car y trouve
wright stein gaulle physiquement apte
riant il ne pense pas que vaille twingo
et le reich rheingold pour lui poincaré
en fait toujours préféré le love and go
et le loft grainger même s'il apprécie
mètres carrés il aurait plutôt aimé
finir avec poincaré le coeur a fini par
avoir raison de la raison et poincaré a
fini par demander à l'offre ingold
quitté m² et love périgord a fini par
accepter
si bien que même si vous aviez annoncé
votre retraite intervillages oise le
maire de ville du coin s'est senti
contraint de vous rappeler pour refaire
de ville du coin la ville de l'amo et
pour éviter tout futur divorce
il ajoute une ligne à votre cahier des
charges il vous faut désormais concevoir
des mariages stables d'où le titre de la
vidéo
pour ce faire le maire lance l'état
d'urgence qui force tous les couples à
se séparer
puis il demande à chaque individu de
ville du coin de révéler ses préférences
chaque individu classe alors ses
partenaires potentiels du préféré ou mon
préféré est avec ces données il vous
faut arranger un maximum de mariage
stable ce qui signifie que deux
personnes non mariées l'un à l'autre ne
doivent pas se préférer à leurs
partenaires respectifs comme ce fut le
cas pour poincaré et love cry roll ça ça
paraît compliqué une idée de comment
faire
et bien la réponse est en fait
étonnamment naturelle elle a été obtenue
par les mathématiciens david guez et
lloyd chapelet en 1962 chapelet gagnera
d'ailleurs le prix nobel d'économie
cinquante ans plus tard en partie pour
d'autres travaux dont on reparlera
l'algorithme de ghayne chapelet le
suivant les carrés vont jouer les hommes
qui propose des mariages et les
triangles vont jouer les femmes qui
acceptent temporairement ou refusent les
cars qui commence par demander leur
premier choix en mariage
chaque femme accepte alors
temporairement la meilleure proposition
qu'elle a reçues et rejette les autres
propositions
ensuite les hommes qui ont été rejetées
demande alors leur deuxième fois en
mariage et là encore chaque femme
n'accepte temporairement que la
meilleure proposition reçue chaque homme
rejeté à ce deuxième tour de
propositions continue de demander en
mariage
la femme qui préfère parmi celles qui
n'a pas encore demandé en mariage et
chaque femme n'accepte temporairement
que la meilleure proposition reçue
quand plus aucun homme n'a de demande en
mariage à faire le processus se termine
et les acceptations temporaire des
femmes deviennent définitives les
couples se marièrent vécurent heureux
sans tromperie et eurent beaucoup
d'enfants qui étaient bel et bien les
leurs alors tout ce que j'ai racontée là
ça peut paraître un joli conte de fée
pour mathématicien mais les algorithmes
de fortes crues personnes et de kyle
chapelet sont plus d'actualité que
jamais à utiliser sans doute pas dans
les ministères de l'amour mais le
problème des mariages stable n'est en
fait pas une histoire de mariage
et oui remplacer les carrés par des
vendeurs et les triangles part
acheteurs et vous obtenez le problème de
l'efficience des marchés remplacer les
carrés par des demandeurs d'emploi et
les triangles par des offres d'embauché
et vous obtenez le marché du travail
remplacé les carrés par des demandeurs
de reins et les triangles par des
donateurs de rein et vous obtenez le
monde du don de rein remplacer les
carrés par des élèves de terminale et
les triangles par des formations post
bac et vous obtenez le problème de
l'admission post bac ou à pépé ça vous
dit quelque chose
dans tous ces cas les nombre de carrés
de triangle sont en fait très très très
grand et ces problèmes doivent être
résolus régulièrement les algorithmes de
ford field personnes et de geisha play
permettent non seulement de résoudre ce
problème sans requérir de travail humain
ils permettent même d'obtenir des
solutions bien meilleure que celle que
des équipes du main très compétent pour
obtenir à tel point que de nombreuses
entreprises ont fait fortune en
organisant la rencontre de quart et et
de triangles par des algorithmes plutôt
que de laisser carré et triangle se
débrouiller tout seul et d'ailleurs ces
entreprises vous les connaissez sans
doute ce sont les mythiques tender ebay
amazon leboncoin linkedin ou autre
monsters et là on tombe sur un autre
problème important à venir pour nos
démocraties et robots les robots les
robots vous vous souvenez il ya quelques
semaines je vous ai dit aujourd'hui les
ja sont quand même pas encore tout à
fait au point en tout cas sont pas du
tout pompé vers du monde pas du tout pas
du tout typiquement microsoft a lancé
tsonga qui était un pote qui parlait sur
twitter qu'ils interagissaient avec les
gens sur twitter et il y est rapidement
devenu
nazis troll en mode ultra fashion
du coup non les ja sont pas encore du
tout prête alors certes mais en revanche
pour de plus en plus de tâches les iae
ou plutôt des algorithmes bien moins
sophistiquée que les ja du machine
learning sont déjà beaucoup beaucoup
plus performante et beaucoup beaucoup
moins coûteuse que des équipes d'experts
pour prendre des décisions qui au final
si on considère l'économie le marché du
travail la santé ou l'éducation sont
véritablement des décisions concernant
des problèmes de société j'insiste là
dessus parce que lorsqu'on pense
transhumanisme bien souvent on pense un
futur très lointain avec des robots
humanoïdes
mais en fait dès aujourd'hui pour de
nombreux problèmes comme organiser la
rencontre d'individus qui ont tout
intérêt à se rencontrer
l'homme est déjà dépassée par la machine
est ce bien souvent pour le plus grand
bien des clients de ces machines mais
enfin on a parlé du paradoxe de bras si
vous avez été nombreux à me dire que en
fait ce genre de paradoxe apparaît dans
des jeux de simulation de ville n'est
tellement simcity 4 et cities skyline où
j'ai pas joué assez je ne peux pas le
garantir moi même mais si c'est le cas
c'est vraiment vraiment trop cool ya
tout à demande si la dictature c'est
mieux dans certains cas
ben là à penser si on a une petite
dictature qui prend toutes les décisions
optimales pour le bien de tout le monde
a posé clairement où il assure en
pratique le problème c'est que souvent
une dictature ne va pas chercher de
faire cela souvent les dictateurs
veulent être et rester au pouvoir comme
déjà parlé et ça ça veut dire qu'ils
vont pas forcément agir dans l'intérêt
du peuple
j'en profite pour adresser un petit
message à ceux qui ont été un petit peu
hooligans politique dans les
commentaires et qui m'ont parlé
d'anarchisme comme si j'avais vraiment
parler de l'anarchisme pas vraiment
parler d'un schisme et plus généralement
en fait vraiment gaffe à ce que vos
convictions politiques ne nuisent pas
votre compréhension du message principal
de la vidéo que je vous renvoie
notamment vers l'épisode 11
on a vu un exercice de maths où les gens
qui avaient des opinions politiques
surtout ceux qui étaient pas mauvais en
math arrivée constamment à la mauvaise
conclusion mathématiques qui était
attendu et carrément plus facile à dire
qu'à faire mais essayez de ne pas
écouter loup l'igad politique en vo
kevin bodin fait remarquer que le fait
de restreindre les libertés c'est
quelque chose dont on a vraiment
l'habitude en fait dans le milieu
familial
après tout les enfants doivent écouter
leurs parents du coup les enfants ou une
liberté restreinte par les ordres de
leurs parents ça s'est vraiment bien vu
comme réflexion souvent dans nos
sociétés on trouve acceptable dans
certaines situations sociales que
certains suivent les ordres de d'autres
il a pas mal qui ont souligné le manque
d'information des conducteurs en
pratique et je pense qu'il quelques
contresens suite à la vidéo précédente
j'ai sans doute pas assez bien expliquer
la chose dans le paradoxe de bresse
l'information est supposé parfaite c'est
à dire que tout le monde sait en temps
réel tous les trente de trajet de tous
les tronçons de route
autrement dit le paradoxe de bras s il
correspond au cas où à l'entrée de
chaque route ya le temps de parcours de
la route et où chacun a accès à un truc
comme google maps qui lui permet de
savoir le temps de parcours de chaque
tronçon en temps réel et chacun réagit
au trafic qui lie à en temps réel sur
les différentes routes de près mais
c'est pas tant qu'il ya un embouteillage
sur certaines routes et que les voitures
y vont parce qu'elles sont bêtes le
problème c'est que certaines routes
restent plus rapide même s'il ya un
petit peu d'embouteillages sur ces
routes en particulier quand il ya
quarante voitures dans le paradoxe de
bresse et que les 40 voitures prennent
les routes de montagne c'est parce que
la route de montagne reste le plus
rapide en ce qu'il ya quarante voitures
que l'autoroute et du coup
individuellement chaque voiture a
intérêt à suivre les deux tronçons de
route de montagne
si le pont est ouvert vincent laurent de
fait remarquer qu'avec les technologies
d'aujourd'hui le gps et le google maps
par exemple il est tout à fait possible
de mettre en place une dictature
bienveillante pour permettre aux
conducteurs de minimiser le temps total
de parcours de tous les conducteurs tous
que de laisser chaque conducteur suivre
son trajet optimal et en effet si demain
google voulait agir pour le bien de tous
il pourra agir en dictateur bienveillant
les minimiser le temps de parcours total
de tous les conducteurs
donc pour chaque conducteur essayé de
minimiser son temps de trajet est là où
le problème peut commencer à se poser
c'est que si google maps fait ça mais
que wade ne fait pas ça ou que par
exemple un peu le map ne fait pas ça va
y avoir une concurrence entre apple et
google
et à ce moment là les utilisateurs
pourront voir que ceux qui utilisent un
peu le match vont plus vite et peut-être
qu'ils vont finir par basculer vers
apple qui minimise les temps de trajet
de chacun des conducteurs mais on se
retrouvera à nouveau dans le cas du
paradoxe de bryce en particulier la
solution de dictateur bienveillant et de
google aura été complètement ignorés
puisque plus personne n'ira utiliser
google ce problème là pour la route
ça paraît pas forcément ultra important
mais il ya une variante de ce problème
qui est le cas des recherches google
aujourd'hui les recherches google sont
personnalisées et on peut se demander si
ça va pas du coup augmenter la
ségrégation idéologique
du coup il faudrait demander peut-être à
google de d'avoir des résultats qui sont
les mêmes pour tous
mais si google commence à faire ça eh
bien il va avoir un autre moteur de
recherche qui va ne pas faire ça et qui
va être du coup préférable pour chacun
des utilisateurs individuellement et à
ce moment là on risquerait d'avoir un
exode de tous les utiliser au revers de
chez google vers l'autre moteur de
recherche et le problème restera et
tekken
vous faites la compétition entre moteur
de recherche fait que tout moteur de
recherche qui subsistent qui a beaucoup
d'utilisateurs est forcément un moteur
de recherche qui personnalise les
résultats des différents utilisateurs et
qui donc augmente la ségrégation sociale
lien un vrai prix de l'anarchie qui
associé à la compétition entre moteur de
recherche très bon train nous demande du
coup ci il faudrait pas rendre le pont
payant que chose comme ça en fait si on
rend le conte payant ça devrait diminuer
le problème
bon après c'est discutable de savoir ce
que c'est l'argent qui le décide et ça
notre critères proposés par cette
conférence et le covoiturage et ça c'est
une solution intéressante puisque au
final ce que vous minimisez c'est
peut-être pas la somme des temps de
parcours des différentes voitures c'est
peut-être davantage la somme des temps
de parcours des différents voyageurs
auquel cas une voiture avec quatre
voyageurs devrait compter plus qu'une
voiture avec un seul voyage war ou
quelqu'un sera carrément du sens de
privilégier le temps de parcours des
voitures avec plus de conducteurs sans
compter bien sûr le fait que du coup ça
m'a favorisé les incentives pour faire
du covoiturage et donc pour diminuer le
nombre de voitures sur les routes et
donc du nombre dont 10 th
enfin wgo yoko ono dit vivement à les
google cars et oui avec les google cars
ou plus généralement les voitures sans
conducteur il aura et sera plus facile
de forcer les gens à suivre une
trajectoire qui sera optimale pour
l'ensemble du groupe plutôt que de
laisser chaque conducteur choisir son
travail de façon optimale mais mieux
encore avec les google cars on pourrait
se débarrasser de beaucoup d'éléments de
la circulation qui sont nécessaire
lorsqu'on a des conducteurs humains par
exemple les feux rouges
et là je vous invite vraiment aller voir
cette vidéo que j'ai faite la semaine
dernière sur une autre chaîne zeta bike
avec le pfl vient interviewer le
professeur boy fighting ce qui nous a
parlé de la différence entre les google
cars et les tesla c'est une discussion
super intéressante notamment sur la
stratégie d'edf
qui a permis à tessa du cas d'annoncé le
fait que les voitures sans conducteur de
tesla seront a priori sur le marché peut
être dès l'année prochaine peut-être
dans deux emplois étaient un peu plus au
temps et l'argument de vente de tesla
pour ses voitures sans conducteur qui
fait que ce truc
beaucoup beaucoup de chance d'être sur
les routes des dans un an deux ou
peut-être 3 max c'est le fait que les
voitures de tesla pour l'instant sur un
track record qui est bien meilleur que
celui des humains
une personne s'est pas assez
statistiquement significatif qu'il faut
plus d'expérience mais a priori d'ici
trois ans il y aura suffisamment de
données pour pouvoir affirmer oui des
voitures tesla sont bien moins
dangereuse que les conducteurs humains
et à ce moment là ça sera une question
de sécurité que de forcer les voitures à
être tout sans conducteur bon il faudra
encore un peu plus de temps pour que
toutes les voitures deviennent sans
conducteur mais finalement tout ça ça
pourrait arriver dans les quelques
années à venir
peut-être dans cinq ans finalement la
plupart des voitures déjà deviendront
petit à petit sans conducteur j'espère
que vous avez aimé cette vidéo la
prochaine fois on va parler du problème
de l'honnêteté
souvent quand on organise des
interactions entre humains notamment via
des machines comme par exemple le
premier mariage stable
on se pose tout de suite la question
basque ont intérêt à révéler vos vrais
préférence à la machine ou est ce qu'il
vaut mieux essayer de jouer un peu le
système est d'être un peu stratégique
rapport à tout cela
c'est un peu le dilemme du vote utile de
façon plus généralisée si vous avez aimé
cet épisode penser à la ligue et à le
commenter à le partager pensez à vous
abonner pour ne pas manquer les futurs
épisodes merci au type heures paulo et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois dix minutes
[Musique]